اغلق سوق الاسهم السعوديه جلسه اليوم
وتراجعا بنسبه بلغت 1.4% و بهبوط وصل الى
150 نقاط وذلك عند ادنى مستوى لهم منذ
ابريل 2021 وكان مؤشر السوق قد ترجع خلال
جلسه اليوم بنحو 190 نقطه ليصل الى ادنى
نقطه عند
9950 نقطه قبل ان يقل ليس من خسائله ويغلق
عند 10,000
و 33 نقطه
ينضم الينا هنا في الاستديو الخبير
الاقتصادي تامر السعيد زي تامر اهلا وسهلا
بك
حياكم الله
من سنتين تقريبا اول مره نستضيف الحديث عن
الانخفاضات اللي تحدث في سوق الاسهم
السعوديه دائما نتكلم عن الهبوط يعني عفوا
الارتفاع والاسود بالارتفاع اليوم لماذا
هذا الهبوط بهذا الشكل
يا زلمه كانت الامور جدا ممتازه وكانت
الاسواق قويه وكانت الظروف مختلفه تماما
اليوم احنا عندنا ادوات استثماريه اخرى
اصبحت تنافس تنافس في العائد ما يقدم وسوق
الاسهم وبالتالي المستثمرين في اسواق
المال بداوا يطلبون اعلى ليتماشى مع
الادوات الاخرى خلينا نقول انه اليوم
اسعار الفائده ارتفعت بشكل كبير خلال
العام 22 بسبب مكافحه التضخم ومحاولات
البنوك المركزيه التدخل اليوم او هذا
الاسبوع عندنا اربعه وخمس بلوك مركزيه
عندها اعلانات فيما يخص اسعار الفائده
وصلت اسعار الفائده تقريبا 6% هذه اعداد
امنه تعطي عائد بمقدار 6% اليوم اصبحت
الخيارات امام المستثمرين هم ان يتجه
ويحصل على 6% كعائد امن خالي من المخاطر
تقريبا او انه يتجه الى السوق الماليه
المتدببه وبالتالي يحاول ان يحقق عائد
بمقدار 10 ونصف او 11% وهو متوسط عوائد
اسواق المال للسنوات ال 15 الماضي فانا
اليوم وفاضل بين العائدين العائد الافضل
هناك نقطه بس اخيرا انه اليوم التراجع هذا
يفسر بانه المستثمرين اصبحوا يطلبون عائد
اكبر من السوق بمقارنه العوائد الاخرى
اللي تحققها الاصول دائما السوق وانعكاس
الاقتصاد او يعني هذه هي علاقه خلينا نقول
طرديه بينهم
الاقتصاد السعودي اليوم يمر بازهى مراحل
تاريخيه تقريبا يعني ثمانيه فاصله ثمانيه
لاول مره
ناتج المحليه كثيره اليوم دولار وارقام
كبيره فائض في الميزانيه ايضا حتى كذلك
لكن الوضع في سوق الاسهم السعوديه لا يشبه
هذا الوضع او خلينا نقول انخفاضات لا تزال
مستمره وشكله يعني رايحه الانخفاضات همم
لا خلينا نقول ان شاء الله في نهايه
المطاف النزول لانه في عوامل اساسيه خلي
يقول في قراءه الاسواق في متوسطات وانماذج
تتحرك فيها الاسواق من حيث الارقام معتاد
عليها المستثمرين هذا الخ واللي يحصل الان
هو خصم يطلب والمستثمرين حتى يحققون
العائد المطلوب همم استثماريه على
استثماراتهم خيراتهم الاستثماريه واحنا
اصبحنا قريبين من هذه المنطقه كثير من
الاسهم الكبرى المتاثره بالاقتصاد اصبحت
تعطي عواء تتجاوز في بعضها ما تقدم ولا
ادوات الاكثر اعمالا فهذه نقطه مهمه لازم
ناخذها بعين الاعتبار في الجهه الاخرى
السوق مراه الاقتصاد نعم ولكن لا ينعكس
بشكل مباشر على همم يعني السوق يسبق حركه
الاقتصاد وبالتالي يتراجع الذي حصل هو
تراجع يعني مبرر بسبب وجود الادوات الاخرى
الاستثماريه الاخرى بالاضافه الى ارتفاع
التكاليف في الاقراض بالنسبه للشركات يعني
احد حكى على اسبابه اخرى يعني ممكن تكون
مش رئيسيه لكنها احد الاسباب على على كثره
الاكتتابات الموجوده على اصدار سندات اللي
حصلت خلال الفتره الماضيه قديش هذه يعني
همم
هي جزء من السوق المشاركين هم اصحاب
الاختيار ما نشارك في الاكتتاب املى نعم
ياخذ جزء من السيوله صحيح لكن الادوات
الاخرى زي ما تفضلت الادوات الاخرى اللي
هي الصكوك وغيرها هي احد الادوات التي
اصبحت تعطي عائد مغري للمستثمرين عشان كده
وبالتالي هو يذهب اليها عوض
نسبه الودائع الزمنيه في تقرير البنك
المركزي الشهر الاخير نمت بمقدار يعني
يعدل اعلى من ديسمبر 2019 بقيمه 60 مليار
15 45 مليار للهيئات الحكوميه الهيئات
الماليه 15 مليار كانت من الافراد
والشركات فاليوم الادوات الاخرى اصبحت
اكثر جاذبيه او تعطي عائد افضل من الادوات
والسلام
على حضورك
الرابعه
السعيد شكرا لك